nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
direction la Méditerranée et la
République turque de Chypre Nord une
entité qui occupe depuis 74 un tiers de
l'île de Chypre et qui n'est reconnu que
par la Turquie pour tenter d'alimenter
son économie Chypre Nord mis sur le
tourisme mais désormais aussi sur les
universités ce petit territoire en
compte 23 avec une offre de diplôme
relativement abordable ces universités
cherchent à attirer des étudiants de
pays en développement avec nous Corentin
Besnier bonjour Corentin vous êtes
journaliste aux observateurs de France
24 et vous avez reçu une alerte à la
rédaction sur les abus de ce système oui
il y a quelques mois deux étudiants au
Camerounais nous ont écrit pour nous
dire qu'ils avaient été expulsés de
chyprenor alors qu'ils avaient payé pour
leurs études là-bas il s'avère qu'il y a
des dizaines de milliers d'étudiants
internationaux hachispreneur il y en a
une partie pour lesquels ça se passe
bien qui sont plutôt satisfaits de leurs
études une autre partie qui
se dit extrêmement déçu ce sont des
étudiants qui se retrouvent sans moyens
de vivre décemment et qui ont du mal à
payer la suite de leurs études et même
du mal à se nourrir à satisfaire leurs
besoins de base on a donc voulu savoir
le pourquoi de cette situation et on
s'est donc rendu là-bas pour les
rencontrer alors on va découvrir votre
reportage signé avec
Erica olavaria et on vous retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
en arrivant la Chine du Nord la police
des immigrants nous ont bloqué
c'est son président le voyage et tout et
vraiment je sais pas quoi faire
ces deux étudiants camerounais rêvaient
de poursuivre leurs études à Chypre Nord
ils ont alerté la rédaction des
observateurs car ils ont été refoulés
sans motifs dès la douane et jamais
remboursé
pourtant ils avaient déboursé des
centaines d'euros pour leur frais de
scolarité cela fait office de visa pour
ce territoire reconnu uniquement par la
Turquie qu'il a envahi en 1974
l'île est depuis divisée entre
l'autoproclamé République turque de
Chypre Nord et la République de Chypre
membre de l'Union européenne
les cas de ces étudiants ne sont qu'un
exemple des dérives d'un système
universitaire aussi attractif que
vivement critiqué
des étudiants originaires du monde
entier dans un amphithéâtre à Chypre
Nord cette image est devenue banale
il serait 50 000 selon les autorités ils
viennent d'Afrique du Moyen-Orient ou du
sous-continent indien et s'inscrivent
dans une des 23 universités de cette
partie de Lille la principale c'est
listeron méditerranéen University une
vitrine pour Chypre Nord
l'offre d'études à Chypre Nord est
relativement abordable entre 3000 et
5000 euros l'année
15 universités voient alors diplôme
reconnu par la Turquie ce qui leur
permettent en général d'être valable en
Europe une perspective séduisante même
si selon nombre d'étudiants sur place la
qualité de l'enseignement agipronor peut
laisser à désirer
[Musique]
encouragé par les autorités les
universités font tout pour attirer des
étudiants
le secteur est devenu une vraie manne
financière pour Chypre Nord il pèserait
un tiers du PIB plus que le tourisme
[Musique]
mais cette émulation génère une dérive
de taille le système des agents ce sont
souvent d'anciens étudiants ils sont
payés à la commission par les
universités pour attirer un maximum
d'étudiants à tout prix
l'association Voice compil des
témoignages d'étudiants mal informés par
leur agent
la majorité des expériences qu'on les
gens quand ils viennent via un agent
c'est qu'il leur disent vous trouverez
du travail c'est facile de se loger ce
n'est pas cher
le premier terrain de jeu des agents ce
sont les réseaux sociaux il multiplie
les promesses souvent trompeuses
certaines annonces parlent d'études à
Chypre sans préciser qu'il s'agit de
Chypre Nord
d'autres évoquent l'Europe sans préciser
que Chypre Nord ne fait pas partie de
l'Union européenne
nombre d'agences promettent aussi des
bourses d'au moins 50% sur les
inscriptions
donc tout le monde peut obtenir une
bourse de 50% mais est-ce que c'est
encore vraiment une bourse si tout le
monde a 50% de réduction personnellement
je trouve que ça sonne bien sur le
papier ça sonne comme une bonne
stratégie marketing
et bien sûr il y a d'autres choses
ridicules comme par exemple de dire
c'est l'Europe vous pouvez bouger dans
n'importe quel pays européen
nous avons parlé avec des agents et ce
qu'ils disent c'est nous parlons
directement avec les parents pas
vraiment avec les étudiants et les
parents ont tendance à croire ce qu'on a
envie de leur faire croire
mais le principal problème ce sont les
universités parce que les universités
sont celles qui payent les agents et qui
refusent de demander des comptes à ses
agents
nous parvenons à rencontrer un agent il
était étudiant en doctorat il assure
faire son métier honnêtement mais
demande l'anonymat
je travaille avec 6 à 7 universités vous
savez comme dans d'autres secteurs il y
a les bons et les mauvaises agents il
manque pour gagner de l'argent
cette question nous préoccupe beaucoup
parce que comme vous pouvez le voir
j'adore l'éducation
un nombre saisissant d'étudiants affirme
être arrivé en ignorant que l'île était
divisé
cet agent assure qu'il parle bien de
Chypre Nord dans ses annonces regardez
mon facebook regardez mon Instagram vous
verrez tout parle de Chypre Nord
pourtant plusieurs publications de sa
page ne parlent que de Chypre pas de
Chypre Nord en 2021 cet agent proposé
par ailleurs un prix pour traverser vers
le sud la partie européenne de l'île
cette illégal et son explication est
confuse ça veut dire que vous aidez des
gens à traverser vers le sud non non non
parce que vous savez au Cameroun nous
avons
disons nous les agents nous avons un
langage que nous utilisons une façon de
parler dans beaucoup de langage de
voyage vous entendez même dire quelqu'un
a traversé à l'étranger quelqu'un qui
vous savez il y a tellement de langage
parce que nous avons aussi des
universités à Chypre sud nous faisons ça
aussi
mais l'homme refusera de donner le nom
des universités avec lesquels il dit
travailler dans la partie sud de Chypre
nombre d'agents sont accusés de jouer
aussi au passage contre environ 400
euros on peut traverser la ligne verte
qui divise l'île
en certains points peut surveiller il
suffit d'enjamber quelques barbelés
les autorités chypriote affirment qu'en
2022 plus de 7000 personnes qui avaient
des visas étudiants pour le Nord ont
traversé la ligne il demande ensuite
l'asile et sont dirigés vers ce camp
[Applaudissements]
les conditions de vie sont difficiles
comme la documentée un de nos
Observateurs ou rêver comme ça
quand on change d'obtenir le statut de
réfugiés elles sont minimes
si des étudiants finissent par traverser
vers le sud c'est parce qu'ils ont été
trompés par leur agent leur condition de
vie au nord étaient insoutenable
[Musique]
Stanley et Paul sont nigérian il profite
de leur dimanche pour faire des courses
mais pas pour eux c'est denrées de base
il les distribue à des étudiants en
détresse financières
pourraient leur valoir une expulsion
c'est dur de trouver à manger sur cette
île je pensais pas que ce serait aussi
dur je pensais que tout serait rose
comme certains le disent
financé par des appels au don
l'initiative s'adresse aux étudiants
africains
Liberia Nigéria Congo Sierra Leone tous
les pays d'Afrique en général nous
entrons en contact via notre WhatsApp
oui via notre groupe WhatsApp nous
proposons différentes choses aujourd'hui
c'est la nourriture que nous distribuons
un autre jour ça sera
des vêtements et des chaussures et même
des plats cuisinés
notamment de leur santé mentale
nous avons pu financer le retour de
quatre étudiants vers le Nigéria et le
Cameroun beaucoup d'étudiants traversent
une phase de dépression et une ondule
pas rouler ils n'ont rien à faire sur
l'île donc plutôt que de les voir causer
des nuisances sur l'île ils viennent
nous voir nous collectons des fonds et
nous payons leur billet d'avion pour
retourner dans leur pays
[Musique]
des boussole et des étudiants finissent
par tomber dans le trafic de drogue et
des étudiantes dans la prostitution
d'autres s'accrochent à leurs rêves
faute deux moyens John a arrêté ses
études ce qui la plaçait en situation
illégale embaucher sur un chantier il a
été victime d'un grave accident
[Musique]
tout à coup je suis tombé de l'immeuble
je me suis cassé des dents je me suis
fait une luxation à la main droite à la
main gauche et à la jambe droite aussi
puis j'ai été emmené à l'hôpital
John n'obtiendra qu'un antibiotique
nombre d'étudiants étrangers sont
discriminés dans l'accès aux soins
il a subitement j'ai vu la police ils
m'ont emmené en prison avec mes
blessures ils n'ont rien fait ils m'ont
donné aucune injection mon expérience de
la prison c'était l'enfer l'enfer avec
l'aide de l'association Voice John paye
sa caution mais il reste expulsable à
tout moment
[Musique]
chaque matin il arpente la zone
industrielle de Nicosie pour trouver un
travail et régulariser sa situation
de trouver un boulot tout ce qu'on me
dit tous les jours c'est il n'y a pas de
poste en ce moment parfois ils prennent
mon numéro
[Musique]
John n'est pas le premier étudiant en
manque d'argent à proposer ses services
à cette entreprise mais à Chypre au nord
les emplois sont rares
[Musique]
j'espère trouver un boulot qui me
permettrait de gagner entre 20 et 30
euros par jour
et je retournerai faire mon Master
coûte environ 4500 euros par an
mon objectif principal c'est d'aller au
Canada et d'avoir une bonne vie pour
entretenir ma famille et aider ceux qui
sont dans le besoin
fin 2022 le gouvernement nigérian a été
le premier à publiquement mettre en
garde contre les dérives des agents
le ministre des facto de l'éducation de
Chypre Nord nous l'a assuré il veut
instaurer un système d'accréditation des
agents et de visa électroniques des
promesses qui ne convaincent pas les
critiques du système
sur place les étudiants le répètent pour
tenter l'expérience à Chypre Nord il
faut être soutenu financièrement et
impérativement faire ses propres
recherches afin de ne pas tomber dans le
piège des agents
voilà pour ce reportage réalisé à partir
d'alerte reçu par la rédaction des
Observateurs de France 24 Corentin
Besnier est toujours avec nous il faut
donc faire attention à ce discours des
agents recruteurs mais il y a-t-il
d'autres choses à savoir lorsqu'on veut
tenter l'aventure universitaire à Chypre
Nord oui alors les étudiants que nous
avons rencontrés sur place nous disent
déjà qu'il faut essayer de regarder la
qualité des universités on peut se
douter que sur un aussi petit territoire
le fait d'avoir 23 établissements ils
vont pas tous être de qualité égale il y
a une chose qu'on peut faire pour ça
c'est regarder si les diplômes de
l'établissement sont reconnus par la
Turquie pas seulement par-cypprenant ce
qui peut présager du fait qu'ils vont
être reconnus ailleurs en Europe et qui
présager en partie de leur qualité c'est
pas le seul critère à prendre en compte
une université qui tire un peu son
épingle du jeu c'est listerne
Méditerranée
deux seules universités publiques de
Chypre cette université là relativement
bien classée dans certains classements
internationaux par exemple elle est
entre la 500e et la septième place dans
le classement du Times d'ailleurs
éducation qui est un magazine qui fait
relativement autorité autre chose c'est
que plusieurs étudiants nous ont signalé
qui avait des vraies discriminations
notamment dans le secteur de la santé il
faut savoir qu'à Chypre Nord si vous
êtes étudiant étranger vous êtes obligé
de prendre de suivre un test de
dépistage du sida une fois par an une
fois par an si ce test par malheur
s'avère être positif vous êtes
immédiatement expulsé vers votre pays
d'origine plusieurs étudiants nous ont
également fait le cas de cas de racisme
c'est le cas notamment d'étudiants
africains le racisme venant de leur
propriétaire dans leurs échanges avec
les commerçants c'est aussi une chose
qui les a pas mal choqués alors Corentin
vous évoquez aussi la les étudiants qui
passent la ligne de séparation pour
gagner la République de Chypre et donc
l'Union européenne pour y demander asile
comment ça se passe une fois qu'ils sont
arrivés dans la partie sud de l'île
alors ils sont dirigés vers un camp qui
s'appelle le camp de pou en arabe dans
lequel nous nous sommes rendus nous
avons rencontré là-bas plusieurs anciens
étudiants du Nord qui se assez déçu de
la situation dans laquelle il se trouve
je vous propose d'écouter l'un d'entre
eux
je vais raconter mon histoire aux
membres des l'Union européenne on va
mais m'accorder directement les statuts
de refuser pour que je sois tranquille
pour le moment je ne peux pas sortir je
ne peux pas travailler puisque je n'ai
pas encore de papier moi personnellement
ça me stresse ce fait voilà si ce
demandeur d'asile se dit coincé c'est
qu'il n'a toujours pas pu faire
enregistrer sa demande d'asile n'a pas
obtenu le récipissé qui lui permettrait
officiellement de quitter le camp il
faut savoir qu'ensuite le temps d'études
de la demande d'asile et peut-être
extrêmement long à suivre ça peut durer
jusqu'à 4 ans jusqu'à 5 ans c'est une
période dans laquelle c'est demandeur
d'asile vivent pour certains dans une
vraie misère ils l'ont beaucoup de
difficultés à trouver un logement à
trouver un emploi du moins légalement
Chypre c'est aujourd'hui le pays de
l'Union européenne qui a le taux de
Primo demandeur d'asile le plus haut par
rapport à sa population le plus haut
dans l'Union européenne la majorité de
ces demandeurs d'asile avaient des
étudiant au Nord selon les autorités
chypriote au final il y en a très très
peu qui obtiennent la de leur statut de
réfugiés ils étaient à peine 300 l'année
dernière alors qu'il y a 30 000 demandes
en attente c'est évidemment une
situation qui contribue à alimenter les
tensions entre les deux parties de l'île
Corentin Besnier des Observateurs de
France 24 merci Corentin c'est la fin de
ce magazine merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
reportage sur France 24
[Musique]